[Music]
let's go to dallin in tampa florida
what's up my man dallin
hey how's it going we're just rocking on
dude
talking about all kind of crazy things
today what are you up to
oh just uh
gearing up for this call and before we
get going i just i wanted to say thanks
for doing what you do man you add a lot
of clarity and goodness to the world so
like i really appreciate what you do we
need it i'm grateful for you man thank
you so what's up dude
so
i
was
i was trying to figure out some things
that are
a bit complicated emotionally for me so
i i feel like i can't quite see the
forest through the trees to
to
make sense of all this
and uh so
feel free to interject and ask questions
if this doesn't have any sort of
cohesive statement to it but um
so my
cohesive statements aren't really my
specialty but i'll do my best
right
i appreciate that
uh
so my dad's currently in jail and has
been for about a year uh what happened
he
well so
uh according to the law i think he had
multiple duis uh to the like felony
level okay so he had all those that had
to get figured out and from what i
understand he'll be out
in like six months or so
um
and uh i haven't been really good with
setting boundaries with him in the past
and in the past i mean the more recent
past mostly because
i can't decipher what is true and what
is not and i know enough to know that
a lot of what he's telling me isn't true
but i think he he believes it
i i suspect that he has been misusing uh
prescription drugs off and on for the
past 20 years or so
and um
my parents divorced when i was really
young when i was nine it was in court
until i was 18. i had a therapist as a
kid and
a guardian that light them and things
were kind of wild back then but it
honestly it
kind of helped me grow up and taught me
a lot but
at the time my dad claimed that my mom
was diagnosed with bipolar or sorry with
borderline personality disorder
and
but i don't know if i can even believe
that and she definitely had all the
earmarks of that from what i've studied
and it makes sense and my dad seemed to
be the same one he was
really smart really well to do in his
career he was doing you know marathons
and just really
an awesome person everyone loved him
and
now
fast forward 20 years and
my mom has become the more stable one my
dad has gone off the rails and so
i tend to not give my mom as much grace
as i should because we have there's a
lot we need to work through
and i i always give my dad the benefit
of the doubt because you know he helped
me out as a kid so much being relatively
stable
and uh but now like i don't even know
what to believe and i don't know how to
set a boundary or even decide what the
boundary is i mean i've got a
family i've got a wife and three kids
and one on the way so we're
you know we need to have our own
space from
from that craziness
and uh he's
he's been in trouble with the law
multiple times and so let me see this
feels busier than it really is
okay so i'm super i'm super glad that
you called
and your dad's in jail so it's a
sensational version but
millions of people
are wrestling with how do i set these
boundaries
and so let me say a couple things these
may have been said to you they should
have been but if they haven't been
your parents divorce had nothing to do
with you
right right
yes
your mom had challenges and your dad had
challenges and they should have
treated you differently and they didn't
and i'm sorry
thanks
you cannot
go back and it's a complete waste of
your time and energy to go reverse
diagnose your mom
and try to quote unquote figure out what
happened
it's an equal waste of time to try to
figure out
what your dad is trying to is he telling
the truth is he not is today a good day
is today not a good day
because what you're doing is you're
waiting on external factors to set your
personal and familial boundaries
and that's not how boundaries work
you set your boundaries what does that
mean
if you're going to be intoxicated you
will not be at this home
period if you are using this season
we're not going to have you around i
don't care if you're
if i feel uncomfortable around you i'm
i'm not i'm i'm gonna do
holidays this way this year
right because i can't even tell he's so
functional with it a lot of the time
okay but you don't want him around why
don't you want him around
i don't trust
that that's it he's just yeah he's too
unpredictable so let me be sometimes
it's great sometimes just not let me be
super clear the only thing you owe him
on planet earth is respect and dignity
period okay you don't owe him your time
you don't owe them access to your kids
you don't owe him a a bed in your home
if you don't want me you don't owe him
you do have to not be a jerk you've got
to be respectful because that's just
human dignity right
um
if you start treating him with
a lack of dignity and respect that's
hurting you not him
right well it hurts him but it hurts you
worse other than that you don't owe him
and you're trying to figure out a way to
keep your kids safe
and to
keep you your
keep your status as his son safe
and at the same time deal with a pinball
machine
right just quit just quit
so so
part of me has toyed with the idea of
like do i just not
engage with them until and i
at all anymore because it's such a i
don't know if it's hot or cold
he gets really delusional too to the
point where he's like they're after me
they've been like it's
bonkers and i'm like i can't go down
that road with you and then he's like oh
you betrayed me for not believing me
you're one of them right and i'm like i
just i can't like i just i feel terrible
just cutting him off and being like i'm
not gonna have a relationship with you
until you normalize and he's like but i
am normal hey listen you're gonna feel
terrible the other way
so the question is not how do i not feel
terrible you feel terrible on both ends
the question is
am i gonna choose guilt or am i gonna
choose resentment
am i gonna choose guilt over
i'm gonna feel guilty when he says you
betrayed me you're one of the alien
finders and i bet you you have a secret
bunker in the bottom of the denver
airport right you're gonna feel guilty
there
or
you're going to resent the fact that
he's sitting on your couch high
he hasn't bathed in a couple of days and
he's given some nonsense to your oldest
kid and he's disrespecting your wife
and that's the thing is it's the
opposite he seems like the most
professional
like businessman ever and it's so like
it plays with my mind and i'm like wait
no okay hold on that's not real that
you're done
be done
be done yeah
you have permission i love him right and
i wanna like those aren't mutually
exclusive man they're both in that's
true
i can love you
i have some of my best friends on the
planet who i love deeply i would never
hire them
they're
wildly unreliable people when it comes
to like professional stuff if i were to
call and be like all right listen
i'm locked in a studio this guy named
james is trying to kill me they would be
like hang on
one of them i don't even think is
legally allowed to drive but they'd be
like i'm gonna get a bus pass and then
it's on give me 18 hours right just
right they'd come they'd show up would i
hire them no chance right so it's not
mutually exclusive you love your dad and
he is not coming to my home
i love my dad and i care about my dad
and i'm putting in boundaries to keep
him and me safe and him and my wife and
my kids safe
so how how would i
proceed moving forward with the
relationship in any way or is it just
like we're not even talking anymore
you're done why did you
when did it become your job
to preserve your relationship with your
dad
i'll tell you when when you were a
seven-year-old kid wondering what you
did to screw up your family
that's why i started this whole thing
with it's not your fault
because you still are trying to duct
tape this thing together man
and you are the kid it's not your job
it's your dad's job to come across the
aisle and hold your face and say i
freaking love you
and my life doesn't work when you're not
in
it and your dad didn't do that
well he
yeah maybe he did and he's not now he
did that well and he still tries to
right
he
he almost over does it to the point
where i'm like okay i got it dad i got
it i get it you love me right but
and then i'm like but you got to stop
like messing around with prescription
drugs you gotta like be clean of that
and he's like no i am i'm doing what the
doctors say i'm like i don't believe you
yeah
you know until it's like
here let's let's take another track get
out of the the conversations
look at actions and behavior that's it
behavior is a language yeah
so i don't care what you're saying i
don't care how i i just all i care is i
think you're high i would like you to
not be at my house
yeah
full stop
and if he chooses to not be in
relationship with you because of your
boundaries that's a choice he's made
that's not on you
right
if you say i will not let you around me
or my kids when you're high or when
you're intoxicated
um
and he's like well screw you you're one
of them then he has looked at his son
and said i would rather choose x over
you
yeah that's hard that's hard
all right
right and if everything seems normal and
the actions are starting to sound
relatively leveled after all of this
is there a way to walk back into that or
i think so
yeah and man all right because the
caveat to that is he got married right
before he went to jail yeah and uh she
what do you do
what's your ultimate goal man what's
your ultimate aim here
i i would love for
i would love to have him stabilize a
little bit on that and then
be able to have the good parts of our
relationship and not the ones that
get delusional
because when we whenever we interact
and it's not
off you know in
the other land all of a sudden it's like
hey we have a good relationship
my kids love him right their favorite
grandparent right and they talk about
him all the time and they wanna
you know he'll send gifts and stuff and
he's just when he's here he'll get down
on his knees with them and play with
them and he just is super present and
it's great
but then also
there's a giant government conspiracy
specifically against him because and he
has this elaborate backstory and i'm
like i can't participate in that
okay if you can't participate it that's
the boundary you're drawing and draw it
and hold it and move on with your life
dude
like you're spending too much time
second guessing your boundaries
yeah and i
i think a lot of it is because i i give
him
so much
benefit of the doubt when i'm like okay
well okay i see what you mean maybe
that's a little believable that
you know you were hey that's that's
that's what you know what
is the 12 year old you still trying to
be like well okay
here here's here's a an outrageous
example what you're describing to me is
exactly the conversation i have when
somebody's in an abusive relationship
right he only listen he only listen he
only hits me when he's really been
drinking and it's fine
usually it's prob like i press it i push
it
like i complain and i get to whining and
then he gets mad so
if i would just shut up then he wouldn't
hit me
and most of the time it's fine and
actually you know what else he's so good
with my my dogs they love him and
they're so good at character judgment
you see what i'm saying
point taken yeah so you can create a
here's there's two fantasies going on
one the fantasy of the perfect family of
dad coming back and being that's not
real man
yeah it's not real so you got to live in
reality
yep and the other fantasy is you can
have it all
you can somehow keep the awesome cool
roller on the floor
and then the guy who is an addict and
not safe
right and you can't do both
or you can but you've got to have some
comically strong um
really strong boundaries and some really
strong implementation guidelines and a
really respectful person who's gonna
hear your boundaries and go all right
time to go and i'm gonna walk out the
door and those man you don't see that
very often it's pretty rare
it's very very special family that can
navigate that
all to say is this be clear about what
you're aiming for and when you aim for
it use reality as a metric
you want a relationship with your dad
great he has to come play
he's got to come play
and he can't play most of the time and
then be abusive just a tiny bit of the
time he can't play most of the time and
then only get high and then come tell
you a bunch of stuff that's going on the
government doesn't want you to know
about
your boundaries are your boundaries they
are what they are and you have a right
to them
make your boundaries firm and strong
hold